the Joe Rogan experience need you to cut
that thing off of us please drive me
crazy that's why I do it
50-year old man took July off of all the
out my internet and everything yeah I
just took it off and I got so bored that
I shaved bald in in my head I saw that
yeah I was just so bored look thanks but
I did it for the same reason I leave
this on my girlfriend hates it I was
trying to shave my head with the back of
you know the back of a beard above a UH
of a trimmer yeah so the back is just
for their sideburns right but I was
trying to shave all my head that's like
40 minutes I was back to like there and
I was like [ __ ] this I'll get it I'll go
buy a real like you know a real beard
trimmer the next day
and I saw my girlfriend she's like hey
what no come on no oh no I'm not keeping
it now I kept it for a month or now I
only checked because somebody died in
the comedy scene and I didn't want to be
at his funeral like that but it was
great dude i bronzed it it was so much
fun I got it once I got a tan you
couldn't really tell you tanned the the
stripe yeah Oh interesting
yeah so it was just full of just a bald
cut it was a lot of fun
how come bronzing is okay but blackface
isn't acting like a Tanner person yeah
what you're acting like you're Brazilian
yeah right yeah shouldn't be allowed
you're acting like you're from Ecuador
or something like you're a jungle person
I have a new theory about cultural
appropriation on here okay so you know
Heights due respect every person's
culture right you have to yeah okay and
if a part of the culture kill you is
wrong like I say about the Chinese
pushing on subway I have been like two
specials ago about Chinese people if
they try to get on an elevator before
you get off that's always a Chinese
person that's almost always a Chinese
person hmm not Asian Chinese but that
part of their culture you don't respect
right no you don't respect everything so
fine white culture is appropriating
other cultures that's what we do best
that's what Elvis did that's what we
crush it at Mexican food hotdogs it's
all appropriating other people's options
that's what we do so you have to respect
that in our culture which is taking on
your culture
like it yes like it cuz this whole
country is a melting pot it's a melting
pot that we are with this country it's a
fondue place that's right you got to
allow us to fondue your culture you can
still use your culture right but we also
can use it why can't you respect
America's culture exactly our culture
says be respected exactly now you get it
and that's why I'm running for president
in 2024 you can't handle me yet he's Ben
Gleib gonna be your vice president vice
president okay my Minister of Affairs I
think Trump is getting a peach is he
getting impeached Jaime you ever see one
you just like I don't even know what you
guys are talking about him I don't trust
the media worth [ __ ] anytime they say
something like I love maybe boy who
cried wolf
yeah every single thing you're like guys
you've just riled me up for nothing over
and over again I don't know what any of
the truth is all these people like what
about this person said this like I've
never even heard that guy what about the
steel dossier what about like Ukraine I
don't know what about Joe Biden what
about when he did what about this week
yeah there's some [ __ ] shitty tweets
we already got that it's already on the
books no one's fighting that anymore to
stop it stop everything cancel everyone
oh shut up all you just shut up
[Applause]